so today i want to show you how these
two sponges different size
can teach us about the potential of our
mind
so why don't we first start off and see
which of these two sponges
weighs more obviously from the looks of
it the yellow one
by far is much bigger than the orange
one we have on this side
the orange one weighs roughly between
six to eight grams
the yellow one weighs 32 grand so we're
talking about roughly
five times as much as the other one this
weighs five times
more than this and what this has to do
with us with our mind is this
there are a lot of people in the world
that have a brain with a lot more
capacity
than others but if we do nothing with it
it's still only going to weigh 32 grams
now watch what happens if this water is
representing
information we feed our mind books we
read things we keep
self-educating self-taught if i dip this
in the water
and it absorbs the water let's see what
this sponge now
weighs from six grams to now
it weighs 76 grams
we're talking about roughly 12 times as
much
this way 32 grams by itself so this is
for example meeting somebody that
without really doing anything they're
already very bright but they don't feed
themselves
and somebody else who might have an
average capacity if they feed themselves
more
they will outsmart the other person that
doesn't feed things
to their mind but watch this watch what
the potential of this sponge is
we're talking about 76 grams here let's
take a look at how much this sponge
could really weigh if it was to
constantly feed itself
in formation obviously i can't get all
the water in there but let's see what we
get here
364 grams
is what this sponge weighs if
it was willing to feed itself
in formation you know when you look at
this and you say well pam what do we get
from this
information here well i've met a lot of
people in my life
who are extremely smart very very
intelligent they have so much capacity
but they're not willing to read i got
some stats for you from huffington post
they studied and they went and did a
research on a thousand people
said 28 of the respondents don't
read a single book a year twenty-five
percent read one to five books a year
fifteen percent read six to ten books
twenty percent read eleven to fifty
eight percent reads above 50 books
per year and you know when you think
about this the next step becomes well
first
what do you feed your mind because 50
shades of gray doesn't necessarily make
you and i need smarter right
what we feed our mind number one two at
what rate do you feed your mind so one
could read four books a year one could
read ten will could read twenty
one could read 50 60 so the rate of the
information we put
to the sponge that we have and the last
one which is the most important one is
implementation is what we get from these
books we're reading here
what do we do to implement them in our
lives it's my message of the week
to you
you